six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try our next caller
from the nine one six area code 905 call
from California it's gone my question
was can you hear me oh yeah okay my
question was what do you think the
likelihood that we'll actually fully get
money out of politics within the next 20
years oh man I would say five percent I
don't know I mean it's it's so hard to
put a number on that because here's the
thing if certain things change then it
would be very likely like if we had a
fundamental restructuring of politics
then it would become very likely that we
would change the financial aspect if the
status quo remains it's just a
non-starter
so like I don't know what is it 5%
chance um I would say it's like a one in
twenty maybe one in ten chance or
something like that what do you think
the the possibility of things actually
changing are I think that there's a
bigger opportunity to start making
intermediate changes so like what would
be and these are gonna sound like
nothing compared to really fixing the
problem but okay one thing would be no
more of this hiding anonymous donors
through other entities it was just made
easier for the NRA for example to hide
the sources of some of their money you
got it every dollar needs to be publicly
accounted for period that will have an
impact that I think would be positive
did not your Supreme Court just make the
decision on exposing what they call dark
money more regularly if they did I
missed it if they did I missed it but I
will look like that but big picture
we've got a long way to go before we
really increase that transparency so I
just think that there are a lot of
intermediate steps that can be taken and
I'm hoping to see some of those taken
and that actually is more realistic
especially because that can be a lot of
that stuff can be done at the state
level and so if the left gets it
together at the state level on some of
these issues and starts actually
building a ground game then we might
actually see some of those changes but
money out of politics the way you sort
of describe as this grand so
lucien i think it's like a 5% chance in
the next 20 years sadly i hope i'm wrong
me too
alright thank you so much for the call
appreciate it